this morning we're exploring a project
to bring back an icon of American
Forests more than a century ago nearly
four billion American chestnut trees
grew in the eastern US dominating
forests from Maine to Florida but wood
log from the massive trees helped build
the country was used in everything from
homes to railroad ties it's famous
chestnuts fed animals and people then
about a century ago disease wiped out
virtually all the trees
chip Reid visited a Virginia farm to
learn how an ambitious program is trying
to restore the once mighty chestnut the
American chestnut tree was once an
American icon a national symbol of
strength and a cornerstone of the
Appalachian economy but today it is
functionally extinct every year it
produced bushels nutritious chestnuts
supported while I thought we've never
seen sense and it also sustained the
people a blight an aptly named type of
fungus was brought to this country
through trade at the turn of the 20th
century and decimated 4 billion trees in
just five decades those remain in the
wild cannot reproduce on their own rex
man as a retired forest ranger who began
volunteering with the american chestnut
foundation over 20 years ago in hopes of
giving the american chestnut tree a
fighting chance you had a health battle
and that inspired you when I retired I
was diagnosed with stage 4 non-hodgkins
lymphoma I had a decision to make I
could do nothing and let nature take
care of it or I could choose to use the
best science we had and try to drive
that monster into remission now for what
researchers say is the first time in
American history of functionally extinct
tree species could be restored what is
the research that you are doing now we
as a science team are trying to develop
an American chestnut tree that has
enough blight tolerance that it could
survive in the forest
researchers at the American chestnut
foundation are breeding the American
chestnut with the Chinese chestnut which
is resistant to the blight sometimes
they don't work after the trees are bred
their burrs which house the nuts are
harvested but in there is a pollinated
bur yeah yep chestnuts inside each one
of these burs are two or three chestnuts
they will be planted and this is just
one step in a long complicated process
that they hope will eventually lead to a
blight resistant American chestnut tree
but before they are planted and bred
again the burrs must be sorted then the
viable nuts will be planted and injected
with the blight to see which ones
survive the young trees that do well
will be bred again tell me why it is so
important to save the American chestnut
tree well it was a way of life in the
Appalachian Xand the eastern US forests
the mighty American chestnut also bears
rot-resistant timber which provided
homes and Industry to the nation's
heartland and with it hope for those who
had little those people were poor in the
fall of the year they would gather
chestnuts by the sack school carry him
down to the country store and swap them
for shoes for the kids and there were
train loads of chestnuts going on to all
the major cities and people bought them
and roasted em on the street now
chestnuts roasting on open fires across
America are of the larger less sweet
European and Asian varieties we want to
tree that competitive in the forest
grows tall and replaces the American
chestnut in that great form and timber
quality if researchers can rescue the
tree the American chestnut could serve
both as a model for protecting other
vulnerable plant species from insects
and disease and as a weapon against
climate change capturing more carbon
from the air thanks to its larger size
we're blazing a trail for how people who
care about this
restore the other trees or illusion I
think that's really the big story for
CBS this morning
chip Reid Meadow View Virginia they're
successful yeah I didn't realize in the
holiday season we're eating European and
Chinese chestnut I do too